well what's your first step in writing a
screenplay what would what do you do
whether it's Emmett's character I have
to it's the hard way I have to be moved
you know I can't just I'm not a writer /
say you know III I can't you can't hire
me as a writer write it would be hard
for me because I know Emmett so well and
then things happen in the news or to me
and I go wow this is this is a great
Emmett story right here I live in my car
for a year I mean as a years ago when I
was much younger but I was homeless for
a year and m it is homeless i also was a
biker for for a long time you know
crashed and all that stuff that bikers
do so I know about motorcycles and he's
a he's done Tod on a motorcycle
basically that's the film that's what
the film is about and some but I know
about it you know if you asked me to
write about hijacking Somalia you know
hijacking boats and stuff I would have
to do a lot of research and reading but
I you know all my life has been kind of
research for Emmett you know he's very
familiar to me and so I right what comes
up right now I what I'm doing is trying
to learn pitching and raise money for
for the feature or for a TV series so
that's what I'm doing now I'm learning
how to do that how do you raise money
pitching is one way you pitched it
studios I'm gonna have to pitch to my
uncle you know later so I'm that's what
I'm learning here so you know and when
the then I'll pitch to my sister and you
know it's a process going back to that
year that you lived in your car mm-hmm
what was humor could you bring to it oh
man are you kidding where do you go to
the bathroom you know where do you where
do you take a shower you know you start
the friends and Friends why'd you why is
he coming here
Musti can you take a shower somewhere
else and you hear these conversations
you know in the next room you know and
you say okay well I'm well worn out my
invitation here you know what McDonald's
will let you use their bathroom how do
you get phone messages you know where do
you park at night when you're living in
your car when you leave your car and you
come back at night your battery is gone
that this I mean a lot of adventures you
know and I watched charlie chaplin and I
go yeah that guy was that that guy was I
don't know if he was homeless but he was
poor that guy was poor why this is just
a sense of that guy knows more about
being uh a homeless guy about about
trying to get a job then normal because
he was there and he did it so there's an
inner there's a voice there's a truth to
to living it and if you can live it and
tell about it it's generally the worst
turns to laughter that's that's
Shakespeare that's true I mean the worst
things that happened to me are now funny
but they weren't when I was going
through it you know I mean you come back
to your car and your guitar is stole and
that's like a tragedy man you will you
can get another that's my guitar keeps
me call you know it's just your battery
is gone how am I going to move the car I
got to get it to the other side of the
street on Thursdays I mean that stuff
becomes funny and telling about it but
when you tell about it people know that
you did it you know you what you were
there and that's why I like em it so
much i can plug a lot I've developed a
character that's a receptacle for for
Larry you know he's got his own life too
Emmett I mean sometimes he says stuff
that breaks me up like he was talking
about begging and he said he says my my
he says my silent partner is the the
church my the church's job is to instill
guilt my job is to leverage it affects
the life of it he's a beggar
you know Emmett said that I didn't you
know it's funny when you're right it's
the character also heads is two cents so
you've already written the screenplay
yeah okay how was it when you first
started like the first seven days I know
you'd had Emmett in your mind for years
versus the last week of finishing that
screenplay it's all the same to me it's
just different stages but it's all
writing it's just you write differently
the first way you do it to me is I just
right it's really it's really funny but
very common against the psychologists
you know your subconscious keeps track
your subconscious is like I I read in a
book that your subconscious is like the
keel you don't see it it's underneath
the water but it keeps you steady you
know that's what keeps their sail from
its the keel that the pressure so the
subconscious um so I start to just write
stuff down anything that occurs to me
you know maybe maybe my car gets stolen
I'll just write anything I know about
cars being stolen or stealing or cars or
but it just write a whole list and other
writers do this too I is not unique to
me but you just keep writing as the
ideas flow until you finally got on
right don't do this anymore I put it
away and then I read it and as you start
to read it you see there's a holy cow
there's a theme here certain ideas in
different forms either car or stealing
or guitar or there's a theme and so you
follow the theme in other words it now
the writing tells you what to write oh
oh this is what my subconscious is
really talking about when I'm what I
think is just blathering on a piece of
page you know so you just follow that so
that's the next stage you just follow
the what the writing is telling you and
then you explore that then you read that
at least that's what I do and it starts
to become into a solid ninh and then you
try to look what's the the
yes the sub structure of the story
because now facts that are related
become a story that one person tells
made it may have started with divergent
people but then old smushes into Emmett
and he's on this trip and then I put him
on a road or something or I put him in a
house and that and then the so the story
comes but how I write is different in
each stage so I keep interested I don't
just work on one kind of thing for three
months you know and sometimes i just put
it in a drawing walk away you know and
this pitch rehearsing for this you know
I would I got a little hand camera you
know and so I would pitch to the camera
and then I would listen to it may God
type it out see what I remembered from
the pitch do it again and I was learning
how to pitch okay you know these points
are important than you want to remember
this but I was learning about the story
I was I was I said wow man I told myself
this story that the screenplay is that
I'm trying to get 96 pages in 25 minutes
or four minutes but I'm learning more
about the story so when I go home and
and the couple of people said okay send
me this the screenplay I'm going to
change a little because I told the story
so many times rehearsing for this that I
saw Wow the story is actually a lot
sharper and tighter now so I can go home
and edit so it's a process it's always a
process you know it's like some painters
never finished painting in the the
artistry Walt he would sell you a
painting and then five years later he'd
knock on your door and say can I have
the painting back I want to change the
rig I mean the painting was never
finished you know you had to agree to
that when you bought the painting and I
may come back in five years on me okay
just M it ever get a steady roof over
his head yeah that's the that's the the
TV version as a TV version where he's a
homeless character like like Charlie
Chaplin we as a neighborhood
beach so I took the motorcycle away from
him he's got this funky old motorcycle
with a sidecar I took the motorcycle
away from him and I just wanted to nail
him down for for the sitcom it's a one
camera but that was about to I guess
other people you know you would want to
make it cheap and keep him one place so
so yeah he became homeless when I took
the motorcycle when I put him on a
bicycle and so he but now he saves
people like Chaplin did or like
basically is Louis CK without the two
daughters in the apartment you know he
he just takes care of things he takes
care of people if you got your shoes
stolen he'll find them somebody breaks
into your store he'll beat up the guy if
he's if there's a you know a bully like
Chaplin later he saves the girl and he's
looking for you know love and a place to
stay the difference is that what he's
looking for is a home and somebody to
love or care for but he also finds out
that he functions best as an outsider
and that's a kind of attention which I
think Chaplin had he wouldn't keep a job
for long what's what's interesting about
that outsider why do you relate to you
can you can function because that came
from a discussion that happens director
a long time ago when I when I was doing
the Emmett show I have a show and so I
was talking to the director and I said
he said why is it homeless and i said i
don't know why is Charlie Chaplin
homeless and he said will you tell me
why is Charlie Chaplin homeless and we
both came to the conclusion that Wow he
wants to be homeless he functions best
you haven't there's a certain freedom
and I mean like even in the marriage a
lot of people are freer in the marriage
because I don't know they bought uh
he below he he Emmett is a survivor he
functions as a survivor he's like an
alley cat or like a cockroach I mean
that's what they do you know some some
things are best left wild you know they
function best that way
you